that I I definitely believe men and
women are not equal right I've always
believed that there's certain things
that women can't get away with in a
certain things that men can't get away
with it but why do we always antagonize
the things that women can get away with
and not the things that men can example
being a man can sleep around he's
because we said this before women want a
man with sexual experience and you don't
want a woman with sexual if you're if
you're having a Malaysia I'll explain
sorry hold on hold on because you asked
so I said women want men with sexual
experience so if you got if you got with
a guy yeah yeah and he had no sexual
experience you wouldn't be attracted to
him why because he doesn't because he
doesn't know what he's doing in a
bedroom
there's not what I'm saying but but okay
so you've got attraction before then
it's time to have sex and he doesn't
know what the hell he's doing okay right
it's are you going to continue that
relationship if he's teachable yes so
like hang on majority of women don't
want to teach men
there's biological reasons for the
reasons we feel the way we feel if a guy
can get other girls that's a form of
pre-selection so so that signals to us
he could take care of those women
therefore he can take care of me too so
that's that's why it's attractive to us
a man that's been with more women on the
other hand men value Purity because
their biological imperative was they
don't want to put resources into a kid
that's not theirs and so that's why they
value a lower body count because if they
don't want to they want to make sure
that kid is theirs and then if you want
to talk about body count so a woman
that's only had that's a virgin when she
gets married she has an 80 chance of a
happy marriage within 10 years
if she's if she's okay again we're
talking about stats so the 80 chance of
a happy marriage in 10 years if you
slept with more than five people which I
think most men pray for nowadays
their chance of a happy marriage is 25
so it goes from 80 to 25 so and and it
keeps dropping lower and lower go ahead
and can I ask you a question so if you
got with a woman who didn't have any
sexual experience
would you um
you teach her okay and if she wasn't
really getting the hang of it a a man is
um more willing to be a teacher of a
woman sexually than a woman is to be I'm
not saying that you're not I'm just
saying but if she wasn't getting the
hang of it what Would You Do Well she'd
get it
in this scenario I'm giving you
she's not getting it so what would you
do well then I'd leave after you got
married so oh after marriage yeah I'm
not having I'm not having I haven't
married you and not had sex with you oh
okay so you'd have sex oh 100 so she
wasn't good in bed you wouldn't marry
her
no like like you were saying if she was
constipated if she was constantly being
taught and she didn't know what she was
doing then the relationship so she so
ultimately she wasn't good in bed yeah
you wouldn't marry her
uh I'd probably seek elsewhere yeah so
you wouldn't marry her why is it such a
is it there's a lower bar for a girl to
be good in bed than there is a man
a man can have sex with a hole in the
wall not know who's on the other side
okay and be absolutely satisfied with
what he just got okay then why wouldn't
you why wouldn't you marry her then
women have sex with a hole in the wall
all you need is a hole right if I can
finish women want to feel a lot of the
time when they have sex
emotionally connected to the person that
they're having sex with and man doesn't
necessarily have to be emotionally
connected so why would you leave because
because of marriage I need more than
that I need more from her it's not in a
marriage than just sex so it goes so why
would you leave if it's not just about
objects why would you leave because
because sex is such is a very big thing
for a man but there's more to it in a
marriage and you can [ __ ] think
that's got a hole all right thank you
if I if I choose a woman if I choose her
and I like her qualities and she can't
have sex right then if if I would weigh
up hmm she's got good qualities Matt
Maria might cheat on her
but if she's got the qualities that she
that is more than just sex I will choose
her okay but if she can't if if if if
she's if she can give good sex and she's
got no wife qualities she's not getting
wet so you'd marry you might marry her
but you cheat on her yeah probably if
she doesn't know what what did you say
it's kind of a reflection of the girl if
you're bad at sex because it's like yeah
no I'm saying like it's a it's a like
she's not trying I feel like if he knows
if he knows it no if he knows exactly
what he wants and he says this is what
you want to do and she's like like I
don't know yeah
same way women know what women can say
to a man this is what I want in a in a
relationship and you don't get it well
the problem is women don't know what
they want so you're making very very
statement because
it's their minds all the time women are
known for changing their mind can I can
I just go back the sex thing
so you
believe that women want men with
experience yeah remember what many
sexual experience yeah we want men with
experience right your experience doesn't
mean you know how to please me just
because you've pleased every woman in
this room doesn't mean you know how to
please my boy yeah but he's shown you
what you know how to do is have sex yes
but he but he's shown you that he he can
have sex how are you showing me because
you told me what your body count is yeah
he's showing you that I like you you
carry it you can you can you know okay
you could you could tell okay
you can you can you can tell if a guy
can get girls you can tell by six but it
doesn't I know you're attracted to guys
that can get girls that's why he got you
what I'm talking about sex right now
having sex are two different things if
it's where you have money then you can
say that but if it's about sex then it's
definitely you know we're talking about
the sexual Market yeah even if it's not
the monetary one at a time I think I'm
delusional because I I think you guys
need to maybe educate me right because
from my delusional brain what I believe
is just because you've had sex with 50
girls doesn't mean you know how to
please me you learn how to please me
from the frequency of how much we have
sex because I always believe the first
time you have sex with someone maybe
feeling lost with each other you feel
like it's height and you enjoy it but as
the sex goes on I feel like he improves
because you get to understand each other
and you know each other's body right so
just because you've slept with 10 girls
or 50 girls or whatever I don't think
you know how to please me you have to
understand why don't you tolerate your
sexual relationship with him then but no
I'm just basing it on what you just said
so I'm saying you can't say your
experience with sex you're good at sex
just because you had sex okay okay no
we're saying we're saying that by and
large men that have sex more tend to be
better at sex okay
I'm not saying that every single guy
that slept with a hundred girls knows
how to screw them right so some guys
don't care they don't want to do that
but by and large like if you do
something more you get better at it if I
play football every Sunday am I more
likely to be a better goal scorer than
someone who doesn't play it doesn't mean
that I'm gonna be Ronaldo okay right but
I'm saying if you have experience doing
something thing that's what attracts you
to the person you know that person has
had sexual experience would you want a
virgin man
you would want a virgin woman yes can I
just say there are a lot of people would
you want a virgin man I did you know
there are a lot of things
but I'm asking you like seriously would
you want a virgin man if he's got
married yeah
virgin man no right so you want a manly
sexual experience yeah but not that much
sexual experience can I just say what do
you mean that much
I've never specified how much that's
what I'm trying to say you're actually
arguing a point that you actually agree
with I don't get it I'm not arguing a
point that I agree with you agree with
the point what I'm saying is in terms of
just because you've had a lot of sex
does not make you good at sex a lot of
people that have had a lot of sex that
think they are good at sex but if you
are the person they last had sex with
they'll be like no I didn't enjoy the
sex my argument an argument is that
women want a man with sexual experience
no one has no one has disagreed with
that though who agreed who
sorry darling my statement was why do
you think because you've had sex with
more people you can please me that's
what my statement was it wasn't about
women but the point I was making is
women as as women as you've said today
women want a man with sex you don't want
a virgin man right you don't want a
virtue but you want to know a man can at
least know
something in the bedroom you don't want
a virgin man so my point is the reason
why it's different for men and women
sleeping around is because men want a
woman who is who has less sexual
experience women want a man with sexual
experience does that make sense but they
both have sexual experience
what'd you mean he said the woman has
less but less but they both have sexual
experience less or zero lessons
can I just ask a question so who are the
men sleeping with what do you mean uh
women with more I'm just trying to I'm
just trying to understand this they're
not women that they sleep with so
they're sleeping with women with more
sexual experience but you've got to
understand they're sleeping with women
with more sexual experience on the basis
that they have no intention to wife them
okay so we're saying earlier on a lot of
a lot of women can have sex with men
yeah
and think that because they're having
sex with men that they're of that
caliber I agree
so men don't it just because you can
have sex with a footballer doesn't mean
well 100 of women want 20 of men and
some some some surveys say five percent
10 15 so you have a hundred percent of
the women sleeping with a smaller
percentage
and yeah so if you all want so like I
said that goes back to you want a memory
sector experience because if women are
looking for that 20 of men we already
know that 20 of men have got sexual
experience because they've got women
frying themselves at them on a constant
basis so have you agreed that just
because you had sex with 50 people
doesn't mean you can please me yeah you
agree with that right
do you have a need to be right right now
is that what it is
yeah no no we said by and large guys
guys that have sex more tend to be
better at sex you said it does not mean
that every single guy that's had sex
with a lot of girls is gonna be some
kind of some some guys are just trying
to get in and get out but you what but
you want that man you want the man that
you know has had sex experience that's
my point you might not be able to please
you but you want him because you know
he's had sex experience you don't want
the Virgin man